[Musique]
dernière tendance avant dernière le
boutis nick cheikh ba oui vous devrez
boire un milk shake tranquillement quand
qu'une personne vous ferez un booty
shake en pleine face à ça c'est bourges
envir jean-michel ce n'est pas en me
fais pas exprès de perdre le bénéfice de
rapidité devant vous un ramequin de
moutarde avec une cuillère il vient
mourir au travail en a beaucoup en vidéo
vous pouvez pas tricher 3 2 1 on y va il
faut le finir
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
ce jour nature et capucine ouais rien ça
se joue en tournée d'adieu à la pression
marie très bien à elle de 2 des odeurs
là encore
il est là c'est délicieux ça aurait très
bien
pour la gold à une technologie c'est
capucine qui a perdu alors
[Applaudissements]
vous devez boire vous devez bord
vraiment tout le reste n'est jamais de
la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
c'est pas possible ça pas debout
[Applaudissements]
passionné à la pause il faut quand même
respecter parce qu'a pu s'acheter des
nouvelles
nouvelles jamais les poupons lots très
bien
j'avais là là vraiment il alla la
résistance je garde un marché que sa
santé est bonne mais là ça va